hi everybody my name is Ralph axel
Mueller I'm professor of psychology at
San Diego State University and I will be
talking about brain connectivity in
autism and I've a little sticky on my
computer to remind me to remind you that
you can answer questions online while
I'm talking and if there's enough time
after my talk I will get to them and try
to answer them so let me start off with
some basic things about autism as you
surely know it's a neuro developmental
disorder that has high prevalence and in
fact increasing prevalence recent
estimates are above one percent so
that's a pretty big public health issue
autism is diagnosed in terms of behavior
criteria which is rather crucial improve
the problem is i will describe in a few
minutes the most recent diagnostic
criteria at least in the US are taken
from the dsm-5 that came out last year
and it focuses on deficits and social
communication and interaction restricted
and repetitive behaviors and these
symptoms need to be present early in
development and they need to be
clinically significant so relatively
severe and not explained by general
intellectual disability and so on now
autism is thus diagnosed as a socio
communicative disorder but it's in fact
much more than that if we look at the
neuropsychological and behavioral
profile
we see that numerous other cognitive and
sensory motor domains are affected in
asd and there's also an enormous
individual variability in heterogeneity
within the disordering the field has
come to accept that from the biological
perspective it's probably several or
maybe numerous meteorological pathways
that result in a phenotype that then
meets the criteria for autism so there
is some kind of convergence in between
biological pathways and the phenotype
people have talked about autism in the
plural and doesn't sound very pretty so
the terminology these days is autism
spectrum disorder that's also how the
dsm-5 talks about another thing that we
know about autism is that there's strong
heritability going back to twin studies
we've known this for a long time however
the problem is that hundreds of genes
have been identified that are somehow
involved in AST and it appears that each
of these genes conveys only very small
risk for the development of ASD on the
upside there's been some convergence of
findings suggesting that many of these
risk genes have something to do with
synaptogenesis synaptic function and
circuit formation and that obviously
already brings us to the topic of my
talk but before I go there I want to ask
some really or a really simplistic naive
question that not that's not the less
important why don't we just cure ASD if
it's some such a big public health
problem and let me raise a few crucial
questions that stop us from doing so so
for fully targeted treatments that could
result in a cure we need some
mechanistic model of the
causation of autism during brain
development and we don't really
understand those causes but we know that
genetic factors are very important but
how do the hundreds of genes that have
been identified trigger the etiology
that leads to a phenotype that we
diagnosed as autistic mmm and then
everybody virtually everybody in the
field accepts that ASD is a brain-based
disorder then why do we diagnose
children based on purely behavioral
criteria well the reason is that we
don't know what the brain biomarkers are
for ASD in that brings me to the to the
topic of my talk so to get started don't
even try to read this slide it might
come out too small on your end anyway
and it's I'm not going going to go
through this in detail at all this is
just a segment of findings on brain
anatomical abnormalities in asd and you
can see that almost every part of the
brain has some findings so frontal lobe
temporal lobe parietal lobe subcortical
structures cerebellum and so on so forth
and I could if I really put everything
that's been found on this slide I
probably have to use a three point font
or so but the point is there seem to be
abnormalities all over the place in the
brain now there are some interesting and
rather specific findings though they do
affect or relate to the brain as a whole
or most parts of the brain going back to
Erica Shane's milestone study in the
early 2000s that have to do with early
brain growth if when we look at brain
grey matter volume this is
the neurotypical growth going up and
then actually a mid childhood starting
to go down again so cortical thickness
actually goes down and that's good thing
in typical adolescence in autism that
seems to be early overgrowth of gray
matter and then accelerated reduction in
volume and these findings overall have
been supported by other groups so that's
a pretty firm findings early over though
finding what's important is that we also
see this in white matter so the white
matter is actually too big early in life
in the first years of life but then
white metal growth which actually
continues in typical development for
quite a long time is stunted in asd so
connectivity is most likely abnormal
from very early on in life so now I will
turn to the core topic of my talk which
is functional connectivity and the
search for biomarkers in network
connectivity well what is functional
connectivity let's start off with a
really simplistic and loose definition
of functional connectivity it's how
brain regions talk to each other at a
later point I will become a lot more
specific but the term is really very
loosely defined and the idea is that
they don't talk well to each other in
AST let me illustrate the very very
simple basic principles of functional
connectivity MRI by looking at our very
first FC MRI study led by michelle
yellow bus almost ten years ago and what
she did is she extracted a time-series
functional MRI generates time series
from primary visual cortex as
illustrated there along the calcarine
fisher and then this time series is
correlated with time series of other
boxes and
so we see an example here of a time
series in inferior frontal voxel and
it's highly correlated in a typically
development participant and much less
correlated in a participant with ASD and
we're looking only at one example of one
voxel that you can imagine how the whole
thing works when you do this for the
whole brain and what we found in this
study was indeed significantly reduced
connectivity between primary visual
cortex and bilateral inferior frontal
cortex and I won't go into the
interpretation of these findings I just
want to say that this fit in very well
with the general literature back then
and the whole thing actually got started
a year earlier by Marcel just 2004 paper
where he looked at sentence
comprehension in autism and the
activation patterns that he found are
shown here and they don't they're not
drastically different but what his group
found was that a number of brain regions
showed reduced signal correlations bold
signal correlations in asd and he
formulated a an under connectivity
theory of the autistic brain that was
then supported by subsequent studies
many subsequent studies from his group
and also studies from other groups and
these lists are not complete these are
examples of studies it is obviously the
EFC MRI literature has grown quite a lot
I can't give you completely exhausted
nas's of studies here but a lot of
evidence at this point suggested that in
fact we have a firm finding here the
autistic brain is under connected see
this review paper punch on news there
however there's a problem there been a
lot of studies especially recently that
are completely art is partially
inconsistent with the general under
connectivity hypothesis
in HD and a disclaimer here right away
you see some studies listed there again
not a complete list about half of these
are from my lap and in fact some of the
earlier ones like I keep on Missoula
study in 2006 it was very hard to
publish this study because back then we
were simply did not want to believe that
there could be something other than
under connectivity in autism let me give
you some examples of studies that show
different effects so this is a study led
by Mark Shen that was an activation fMRI
study looking at symantec decision and
you see the activation clusters here the
biggest one in broca's area left
inferior frontal cortex and what we did
in the functional connectivity study is
to use the cluster of shared activation
between both groups we use that as a
seed for functional connectivity
analyses and those are the results that
we find and in the GD group we see
relatively distinct functional
connectivity findings in austere Paris
olean cortex Wernicke's area and then
also on in the homotopic inferior
frontal cortex and the other hemisphere
the right hemisphere in asd above the
picture looks much more distributed and
diffusion direct group comparison
actually shows it shows us that many
parts of the brain are over connected
with inferior frontal cortex in asd so
we have diffusely increased both
correlations in another study we try to
dig a little deeper and understand how
that might be related to the
organization of cortex in this study led
by patty she we looked at posterior
superior temporal sulcus and we
identified three
sub regions within osteria superior
temporal sulcus that were functionally
distinguished a rostral region in middle
PST s region and a card or region the
color coded or the connectivity patterns
are color coded here and you can see
that they're quite distinct so we don't
have much overlap between those you read
a connectivity areas for the middle seed
and parts of the brain that are
connected to the caudal and rostral
areas those two however show relatively
similar connectivity patterns when we
look at the ast group we see much less
differentiation so when you look at the
these dark areas those show shared
connectivity for all three sub-regions
in PS TS so that is what i mean by
reduced differentiation of connectivity
parents now interestingly this reduced
local differentiation was associated
with over connectivity and again same
color code here you see regions that
show significant over connectivity in
asd so we have two findings basically we
have a reduction of local functional
differentiation and an increase in
long-distance connectivity and these two
seem to go together they are associated
and it's expected that these or one
could assume that these are two
manifestations of the same
neurodevelopmental have normality now I
owe you an explanation because I've been
telling you or started off by telling
you they're all these studies that show
under connectivity in AST and now its
own i'll show you tuesday
is that show the opposite so what's
going on here so let's step back to the
very first steps in FC MRI research that
goes back to bar this one's work in the
mid-1990s so what we see here is an fMRI
activation result for bilateral finger
tapping you see activations in
biological motor cortex and
supplementary motor area and what his
group did was to pick out one of these
new primary motor cortical activations
and apply these this cluster as a seed
to a resting state data set and now in
the picture on the right you see resting
state correlated resting state
fluctuations in the rest of the brain
and you can see that the correlation is
specifically seen within motor cortex so
there are spontaneous fluctuations
within the motor network and since then
thousands of study have used this
approach to map out various functional
networks not just the motor Network you
can apply this to pretty much any
network subsequent work has shown that
the important signal correlations are
found in very low very low frequency
domain below point one Hertz is work by
kima Cortez these are basically the
interest interesting correlations that
are driven presumably by neuronal
fluctuations whereas the rest is the
other colors indicate physiological
noise why do we think it's neuronal
activity well some studies have shown
that there is actually linked to slow
fluctuations in local field potentials
and interestingly as well these low
frequency fluctuations of the volt
signal can be modulated by learning and
practice
and they are thought to reflect hebbian
plasticity but most interestingly for
our purposes here is the fact that these
are fluctuations that occurred
spontaneously you can find them in the
absence of a task that brings me now
back to our question nasd and are
inconsistent results so functional
connectivity results depend on design
and type of analysis and we can
distinguish two broad types of analysis
one is coactivation or I'm call
coactivation functional connectivity MRI
and here we're looking at correlations
that are driven by a task or by stimulii
and these studies tend to focus on
effects between activated regions of
interest and they tend to find under
connectivity in asd on the other hand we
have an approach that's called intrinsic
functional connectivity MRI where we
look at it spontaneous low-frequency
fluctuations use low band pass filtering
to isolate those fluctuations and if
there if we have a task or stimulus
presentation we actually remove those
effects statistically all we use the
resting state come back to that later
these studies actually tend to generate
over connectivity findings in asd ok so
I'm claiming that but why would you
believe me well let me try to convince
you first of all we did a literature
survey a few years ago where we looked
at all the FC MRI studies that have been
published in SD to that point 32 and we
sorted them by their findings those that
found under connectivity only and those
that found over connectivity or partial
over connecting they're color-coded here
and what we found is that these two
types of studies and
differ significantly in their
methodological fingerprints that are
illustrated here with this radar plot
and the significant findings were for
low pass filtering so all studies that
have shown over connectivity had used
low pass filters where is only half of
the studies that resulted in under
connectivity hardly any of the studies
under the under connectivity studies has
had used task regression removal of a
task or stimulus effects whereas most
studies finding over chronically had
done that and a third significant
findings for a field of view virtually
none of the 21 studies that had found
under connectivity in HD had actually
looked at the entire brain to see
whether there were maybe inverse effects
elsewhere whereas many studies that have
found over connectivity having looked at
already we've since then followed up on
this literature survey study with our
own empirical investigation using three
datasets to task datasets and one
resting state fMRI data set to directly
compare the effects of methodological
variables so we analyze these data sets
along competing pipelines and summary of
findings is that there were significant
effects for type of analysis so
coactivation analyses tend to yield
under connectivity findings in this
graph up and intrinsic FC marine
analyses tend to your over connectivity
findings down in this graph and a
significant finding or field of view so
if you only look at regions of interest
you're very likely to find under
connectivity but it's different when you
look at the whole brain so the crucial
variables are temporal band pass
filtering to isolate low frequency
fluctuations and if there is a task
regression regressing out the model to
task effects studies that focus on high
frequency task driven effects will tend
to yield under connectivity and ASD
studies that focus on low frequency
intrinsic correlations will tend to
yield over connectivity findings is in
SD and these over connectivity findings
occur mostly outside activation are wise
so if we only look at activation to ride
otherwise we might not see them now
there was another finding in this study
that the data set used also had a
significant effect and I can't discuss
this in detail but I will come back to
the resting state issues with the
resting state a little later so what
does all this mean for ASD rather than
having a general principle of under
connectivity in HD I think that points
towards a dual impairment in AST so if
we look at a cartoon network on this
brain here so it's not supposed to be
actual regions but just kind of
simplistic illustration here so we have
integration in the TD brain between
three nodes of this network and this
integration is reduced in HD however
that's not all we also have a typically
increased connectivity outside the
network so reduced differentiation
between networks these regions are not
supposed to talk to each other a lot but
they still do in asd an example was the
language that we're talking too much
that's a typically to visual cortex and
one of the studies that I'd showed
earlier
so using a metaphor we could say that we
have impaired network sculpting in asd
and this actually relates to the model
by Mark Johnson or how networks form a
typical development mean they're
basically two two mechanisms types of
mechanisms progressive mechanisms like
myelination and synaptic strengthening
and regressive mechanisms like synaptic
pruning neck sonal loss and obviously
these are experienced or activity driven
both of these are impaired or appear to
be impaired in asd resulting in
inefficient network organisation what
would call noisy information processing
and in fact this approach is also model
is also very consistent with some recent
work out of the UCLA group neurologic
rattle Susan Polk high school let me
show you one more study a recent study
by you know fisherman and a fisherman
who looked at mentalizing and mirror
neuron systems in asd the theory of mind
and M&S networks and what she found was
that although there was a pattern of
both over and under connectivity when
looked at
you
you
we might be back here okay um that would
back okay all right I'm sorry about that
we had some technical problems here so I
was trying to go to the next slide so
basically I've been showing you a bunch
of findings that support this network
sculpting model before it gets too
pretty I want to bring up some problems
here or caveats one of them there's
probably some regional and network
specificity in these principles that I
described let me just give you one
example a study where we looked at
connectivity between thalamus and
cerebral cortex and you can see several
cortical regions here that used as seeds
and we can do a parcel ation of thalamus
based on anatomical connectivity color
coded in the same way it comes out
pretty similar in typically developing
in asd groups however there are
significant differences in anatomical
connectivity from DTI which I will turn
to in a little bit we see under
connectivity reduced connection
probability between various or for all
of these cortical scenes in thalamus and
we also see a functional connectivity
MRI reduced functional connectivity the
findings are not always exactly the same
but there is obviously quite a lot of
convergence your findings with the
exception of findings for temporal lobe
and connectivity talents some of these
findings are related to Diagnostics but
not all of them and this is not always
very straightforward I can talk about in
the Q&A if you
want to complicated story two things so
so this is an example of regional or
network specificity here the principles
that I mentioned don't seem too well
apply in the same way and this is
probably also true for some a cortical
networks to added comments here we used
resting-state functional connectivity
MRI here and DTI have to talk a little
bit TTI so let me do one after the other
let me say a few things about the
resting state can we assume that when we
put participant with ASD into a scanner
that they will respond to an undefined
condition when we just tell them just
relax in the same way as a typically
developing child probably not actually
and there's actually some evidence so
let me give you one example that's Dan
Kennedy's fMRI study where he looked at
deactivations actually during task
performance compared to the resting
state and these deactivations reflect
activations during the resting state and
you can see these blue clusters on the
left there that's the default mode
network that is actin tends to be active
during the resting state in typically
developing adults and you can see that
in adults with ASD that was not seen at
all so he called that failure to
deactivate so the problem is that if
kids with ASD go into cognitive states
that are different from those seen in TD
participants during this resting state
we don't really know because we don't
have any control over it and it's very
hard to monitor that so if we have
findings of under connectivity within
the default mode network in resting
state see MRI studies we don't really
know whether that maybe just because
kids with ASD don't go into this default
mode and one way to try to approach this
is by looking at dynamic changes across
time in functional connectivity to
address the question of whether some
children with ASD maybe go in and out of
the default mode and we find that in
some cases so these are some examples
and you can see that the connectivity
between the default mode Network it
stays close to ceiling in these two TV
participants and they go up and down the
connectivity goes up and down across
time in asd participants but this is our
selective example so this is still the
non room study but what Mark Marley in a
presentation at SF and found was that
regions of interests that are under
connected in asd tend to also show
increased variability across time so
that's consistent this general idea that
it's because of their ability of
cognitive states that we have these
findings so as promised I want to talk a
little bit about anatomical connectivity
diffusion tensor imaging being the
technique of choice here just very
briefly how does this work we look at
water diffusion we look at a fire our
track here shown vertically in this
cartoon these circles and ellipses
indicate water diffusion that's what we
pick up with infusion tensor imaging we
go outside the fiber trunk saying we go
into CSF diffusion is isotropic the same
in all directions but inside our primer
track it's an isotropic so from a
fractional anisotropy is up inside a
hive attract and there are other indices
like me and radio confusion mean
diffusions just the overall diffusion
also Goes Down Goes Down within
five attract and so does radio diffusion
indicated by these arrows they're also
reduced the five attract so increased FA
and reduced em gain and RTI signs of
well organized white matter fiber tracts
just one example of an ESD study using a
track based spatial statistics which is
a technique that allows us to map out
the main 50 tracks across the brain in
green here and so-called skeleton and
then test for differences in these DTI
indices across all these fiber tracts in
the red spots on these images indicate
regions of significantly reduced
fractional anisotropy in children and
adolescents with ASD and you can see
they found widely in many different
parts of the brain many different tracks
another index of white matter compromise
is increased mean diffusion and again we
see this kind of finding many tracks
across the whole brain and the same with
increased radio confusion and don't
worry about all these abbreviations
these are these are different tracks and
the take home message here is solely
that we have widespread white metal
compromise and there's largely
consistent evidence in a pretty large
number of studies in children
adolescents and adults with ASD cited
here only a couple recent ones there is
a very recent caveat study from Nancy
khandwa sures group suggesting that
differences in head motion might be
behind some of these FA differences
however the study that I showed you and
that study on groups were matched for
head motion this is obviously a serious
concern but I'm I don't think all these
findings will go away completely once we
learn how to address motion confirms
better
pti research a more important caveat is
that patterns in infants and toddlers
are probably very different and show you
two examples from this so far very small
literature this is a study by banker
shot scoop looked at fractional
anisotropy and children between ages one
and a half six and you can see that in
fact FA in part of the corpus callosum
was increased rather than reduced and in
that age group they found that also in
other parts of the brain it's just an
illustration for one part or corpus
callosum here and we're looking at the
same segment of corpus callosum here in
another study by a consortium group
study led by wolf colleagues now the
principal finding is the same that there
is actually increased FA very early in
life in asd however the timing is very
different in this study so according to
this study this only is true up to maybe
12 to 15 months of age but the
conclusion at this point is the same
there is early white matter overgrowth
or these findings in FA findings could
be related to early white matter
overgrowth it's very tempting to read
that and it also again drives home the
fact that connectivity is quite
certainly aberrant in AST from very
early on in life now what i've shown you
though so far are have been mostly
studies that focused on specific
networks specific regions of the brain
specific tracks of the brain and i want
to make the point from the end of my
talk
these approaches these hypothesis-driven
approaches might actually not be
sufficient in asd let me explain why
it's really very very easy in asd to
find the rationale for just about any
hypothesis if you have an area of the
brain that you really like and you
really want to claim that it has
something to do a causal link with ASD
you will find some supportive evidence
in the literature I gave you an example
of MRI anatomical MRI study exactly at
the beginning of my talk but that's true
for many other types of techniques we
have too many findings but on the other
hand we don't have enough strong
compelling and replicated findings for
strong hypotheses for unique biomarkers
biomarkers may be very complex and they
may include unexpected brain patterns
that at this point we have no basis of
hypothesizing and importantly as well I
talked about the probably existence of
subtypes of ASD at the beginning of my
talk now complex biomarkers may actually
be clusterings of complex brain patterns
so it is very important as a first step
in an idea what these biomarkers could
be so that we can then approach these
questions and all of these questions
require data driven approaches for
investigation so let me give you some
really simple examples first of
data-driven approaches and the first one
study led by Ryan cardinale used
independent component analysis
and resting-state functional MRI
independent component analysis can map
out functional networks in a data-driven
way and these networks are characterized
by shared temporal variance maximally
independently when you run ica on mi
data you end up with some noise
components and you can throw them away
and then you end up with components that
you have criteria for selecting as for
true components functional components
and we found found 13 of these
functional networks that were well
matched to networks known from the
literature and 10 of these showed
differences in asymmetry hemispheric
asymmetry and the interesting finding
here was that all of these showed
rightward asymmetry shifts in asd so
there appears to be a persistent shift
in hemispheric asymmetry in AST now
that's interesting and that's almost a
different topic here but without
data-driven approaches we would not have
been able to find this because these
networks are not defined by any
particular hypothesis or regions of
interest but they are data-driven graph
theory is another type of approach that
allows us data-driven characterization
on connectivity abnormalities in asd in
the study led by christian in my lab we
looked at local connection density
within a 14 millimeter radius and these
are the density patterns across the
whole brain in TD and ASD children and
they look overall similar you see very
hot regions of high density in posterior
visual cortex and also medial prefrontal
cortex however a direct group comparison
shows us that they are
significant differences in posterior
cortex primarily visual cortex
highlighted here circled but there are
also some adverse effects of local under
connectivity or interior regions the
really important finding in this study
was that these over connectivity
clusters in posterior cortex or the
degree of over connectivity was
associated with symptom severity in the
ASD group suggesting that there are
links between symptomatology and local
connectivity now probably the most
important approach data-driven approach
in asd is diagnostic classification if
we can train an algorithm to tell us
this brain is autistic this brain is
typically developing then we're getting
very close to finding those biomarkers
this is an example study by Jeff
Anderson's group using resting-state
functional connectivity MRI matrix and a
very large matrix over 7,000 regions of
interest and a sample of 80 participants
in a very small validation sample and
one interesting finding that they made
is when they looked at their
connectivities by euclidean distance
here on the x-axis they found a lot of
under connectivity the blue the blue
cells there these reflect under
connectivity in autism for connections
that were mid to long distance and
interestingly these tended to be the
most informative connections informative
in the sense that they were stronger
this most strongly contributed to the
diagnostic classical classification a SD
vs TV however the overall a prediction
accuracy was only about seventy percent
in this battle so this is still
relatively low colleen shannon my lab
has been pushing forward this diagnostic
classification efforts using machine
learning these studies we actually use
consortium data from the abide
consortium in a larger sample selected
from the fine without no motion of
datasets high-quality data sets resting
state 220 are wise from these the
machine learning algorithm selected a
hundred most informative features and we
reach a classification accuracy of close
to ninety one-percent with a nine
percent error rate in the outer bag
validation sample now let me show you
those most informative features that's
the connector Graham and frontal lobe at
the top occipital lobe the back of the
brain at the bottom subcortex at the
bottom and you can see this is not very
obvious there's not a very obvious
pattern the right stuff is over
connectivity that Lou stuff is under
connectivity and ASD that suggests that
there may be very very complex patterns
of a typical connectivity that we need
for diagnostic classification when we
look at specific my networks we see
slightly more of a pattern and what's
interesting here is that some other
sensory networks seem to be
disproportionately important for
informative for diagnostic
classification and that relates in
interesting ways to the growing
literature on sensory motor
abnormalities in HD all right let me
come to some conclusions so I hope I've
been able to convince you that there are
that there's a lot of evidence
on aberrant functional and anatomical
connectivity but when we get to the fine
print or the specifics it becomes more
complicated in conventional model of
general under connectivity definitely
requires modification an alternative
model that I've characterized with using
the metaphor of impaired Network
sculpting seems to be more adequate
describing the literature which shows
reduced integration in other words under
connectivity within neurotypical
networks but also reduced
differentiation in HD diffuse over
connectivity outside neurotypical
networks aberrant connectivity is
probably present very early in the
autistic brain that is supported by
findings of early white better over
growth but also are some tantalizing
recent findings of what appears to be
precocious aspects of maturation in use
one of two and maybe a little later from
infusion tensor imaging in depth again
probably really relates in interesting
ways to the evidence on third of early
sensorimotor abnormalities in HD so why
is all this important coming back to the
questions that are raised at the
beginning of the talk as I stress then
we need biomarkers for HD to get away
from behavioral diagnostics and measures
of network connectivity are likely are
very promising to yield such markers
biomarkers may be very complex I've only
shown you an example from functional
connectivity MRI but of course we want
to include other MRI models at
modalities and other neuroscience
techniques in this effort as well so
they may actually become even more
complex but they may allow us to
identify grain-based subtypes of ASD
based on clusterings of biomarkers why
is this important
well it identification of these
grain-based subtypes opens up really
important perspectives because one would
hope that for each of these biologically
defines subtypes the links with specific
genetic and environmental causes may be
more transparent I'd actually like to
change my slide maybe more tractable
okay transparent is probably too much of
an expectation but hopefully they'd be
more tractable and obviously this would
be a first step to a mechanistic model
of what causes autism in brain
development which is a prerequisite for
fully of fooling targeted treatments
that will allow us to cure this disorder
all right thank you very much for
listening and thanks to the participants
in our studies to the funding agencies
and the many people in my lab and
outside the lab it helped with these
studies and I will now go to the Q&A
actually asked to bring up a slide here
that reminds you that you can get CME
credits this box and see okay so apart
from Diagnostics does the finding of
poorer connectivity have any therapeutic
implications well I think this may have
been a question that was asked earlier
on I think I just made it clear in my
last slides that in fact the reason why
we're doing this connectivity work is
that we are looking for biomarkers that
put us on the way to being able to
identify subtypes of the disorder and as
I try to explain this is a crucial step
to unraveling or disentangling the
etiology that lead to a phenotype that
is diagnosed as a SD second question is
it possible that autism or ASD could be
a dysfunctional dysfunction in the
pruning period well I surely think that
the functional connectivity findings
that I presented reflect reduced ruling
in asd now I do not believe that there
is one specific mechanism or parameter
of brain development that can be picked
out and that will explain the entire
developmental causation of the disorder
so I would say that reduced pruning or
impaired pruning probably plays a role
that it's really only one factor and it
plays a role or it can account for these
effects of diffuse over connectivity
outside network over connectivity that
we see in asd I showed you several
examples of studies that are showing
this so the question obviously is is
this a primarily biologically effect
maybe gene driven or is this actually an
effect of reduced experiential
plasticity because we know that kids
with ASD don't interact with the
environment in normal ways so it's
possible that reduced experiential
interaction with the environment
actually is a major factor in the
reduction of experiential effects of
pruning on next question
is there a possibility that asd would be
perhaps an epigenetic issue yes I should
have probably mentioned that when i
talked about genetic factors that in
fact is growing evidence that it's
potentially an interaction between
genetic factors and and environmental
factors genes that make a child child's
brain more susceptible to environmental
toxins for example that was actually an
oversight I should have mentioned that
earlier so this this is absolutely
possibility another question two minutes
okay SD is more common in males than in
females have they been observed
differences one could open this question
in brains of male versus female right so
I can't see the end of her question so I
see down there male vs females with
autism now the problem is that obviously
there is high ratio male to female ratio
in the SD in high functioning ASD this
racial kind of tends to be even higher
than four to one so many studies include
including our studies include only
relatively few participants with
Portland participants that are girls or
women so in terms of the findings that I
showed at this point I cannot tell you
what differences there made between
female and male functional connectivity
for example and I don't know of any
studies that have looked at
systematically at that there's some
studies that have looked at differences
in brain anatomy but not there is not
much evidence for connectivity next
question should the search for cellular
and molecular mechanisms also shift from
hypothesis driven towards a data-driven
analysis well yes and I think that's
already happening I think for example a
large consortium of genetics studies
have used a data-driven bio informatics
tools that's not my specialty but yes
the answer is probably largely yes once
however once we have a clear idea about
biomarkers then of course we have to go
back to two hypothesis-driven studies
how does childhood disintegrative
disorder fit in the big picture of ASD a
burn connectivity and biomarkers I
apologize I don't know enough about
childhood disintegrative disorder to
answer that question so perfect timing
we are out of time so thank you very
much again for your interest